[Música]
vamos a hacer un experimento
miren alrededor de este auditorio
observen los colores objetos rojos
listos ahora cierren los ojos
recuerden cuatro objetos azules
abre los ojos
interesante este experimento nos ayuda a
reconocer cómo solamente recordamos
aquello donde ponemos nuestra atención y
eso se vuelve nuestra realidad
es más le hemos preguntado a miles de
personas donde suele estar puesta
nuestra atención y siempre nos responden
lo mismo en los pensamientos la
fundación de la ciencia de eeuu ha
señalado que tenemos entre 12 mil y 60
mil pensamientos por día eso es como un
pensamiento cada 1.3 segundos y bueno
sería que esto fueran paradisíacos o que
nos apoyasen sin embargo no es así no no
ese mismo estudio nos dice que 80% de
estos pensamientos suelen ser negativos
95% de ellos repetitivos es decir los
mismos que ayer y anteayer se imaginen
la implicancia que tiene es nuestras
vidas vamos con otro experimento vamos a
cerrar los ojos
vamos a imaginar que tenemos un limón al
frente lo partimos le quitamos las
pepitas lo llevamos a la boca y
exprimimos todo ese jugo en la boca
abramos los ojos se hubieran visto la
caja
es increíble pero el cerebro no
distingue lo imaginario de lo real se
imagina en el efecto que tiene los
pensamientos en nuestro cuerpo
sobre esto no es sorpresa pues que la
organización mundial de la salud haya
señalado que 300 millones de personas
sufren de depresión y más o menos la
misma cantidad de ansiedad pues suelen
ir de la mano
es tan grave la depresión que el
suicidio es la segunda causa de muerte
entre jóvenes y adolescentes
y esto siguiente que voy a decir me es
difícil decirlo
una persona se suicida cada 40 segundos
así como nosotras que sentimos cierta
incomodidad al hablar de esto hasta
inclusive dolor tales ustedes también lo
están sintiendo pues no estamos
acostumbrados a hablar de esto en
nuestra sociedad es tabú hablar sobre
las enfermedades mentales
es tan tabú que el 80 por ciento de
personas con enfermedades mentales en
nuestro país no son diagnosticadas ni
tratadas
respecto a esto se sabe que una de las
causas entre caer en la depresión y la
ansiedad es la tendencia a engancharnos
a estos pensamientos que usualmente son
negativos y catastróficos en relación a
nosotros y el entorno este piloto
automático en el que no dejamos de
pensar se llama rumiación así como las
vacas las vacas romea mastican una y
otra vez el pasto para poder digerirlo y
nosotros las emociones placenteras o
displacenteras que no podemos digerir es
decir que no podemos dejar ser ni dejar
ir las rumiamos no les ha pasado estar
en la playa o en el trabajo o en una
comida familiar y no para de pensar en
automático
y porque rumiamos pues estamos
insatisfechos con la vida tal cual está
haciendo
y en la parte más primitiva de nuestro
cerebro el sistema límbico hay una
programación que nos hace recordar y
prestar atención sobre todo aquello que
nos hace sentir inseguros y amenaza
contra la supervivencia de nuestra
especie por ello nuestros antepasados
necesitaron recordar donde vivía el
jaguar y cuáles eran las plantas que
podían matarnos sin embargo hoy
reaccionamos del mismo modo primitivo
paralizando nos luchando o viendo
ante un problema con la pareja o una
dificultad en el trabajo pues nos
sentimos del mismo modo inseguros y
amenazados eso nos lleva a vivir en el
carril de alta velocidad haciendo lo que
sea para hacer los mejores profesionales
los mejores estudiantes la súper mamá y
el súper papá inclusive pues vivimos en
una atmósfera de competitividad regida
por el crítico interno que nos mira con
pensamientos como cuidado que quieras tu
trabajo no está haciendo lo suficiente
buena madre esposa o padre ni siquiera
está haciendo suficiente buena speaker
-entre o facilitadora de mindfulness
si las emociones han evolucionado de
estas conductas primitivas tenemos
emociones que son placenteras y ricas de
sentir como la alegría por ejemplo se
siente con el pecho abierto hombres
relajados es delicioso ser feliz
entonces uno busca situaciones que le
generen esa felicidad así por ejemplo me
encanta estar con brisa entonces la
busco y eso me genera felicidad el estar
con ella va a hacer que yo tenga más
probabilidades de sobrevivir
por el contrario si yo tengo emociones
negativas no se sienten cómodas en el
cuerpo no se siente el pecho apretado
por ejemplo con el miedo o la tristeza o
la ira es tan incómodo que nos alejamos
de esas situaciones y si no podemos
alejarnos de ellas físicamente nos
alejamos de sentirlas como justamente
rumiando yéndonos a pensarlas o quizás
con la comida con el trabajo con el
alcohol pero todas estas estrategias de
resistencia no hacen más que perpetuar
esa emoción funcionan como una cortina
de humo que no te hace ver la realidad
como dice el psiquiatra carl jung lo que
resiste persiste y nosotras desde
mindfulness decimos lo que se atiende
plenamente se trasciende pues es a
través de esta práctica que nos invita a
conectarnos con lo que está haciendo tal
cual está haciendo para conectarnos con
nosotros mismos a conectarnos con el
otro con los demás con el entorno
es decir nos presentamos a la cita que
tenemos con la vida pues está la ten
presente suena en presente huele en
presente y es justamente a través de
este modo en que aprendemos a atender no
solamente qué ni cómo ni cuándo sino
también cómo responder a ello desde la
sabiduría y la compasión ya que nos
referimos con sabiduría y compasión en
este contexto
la cualidad sabia de mindfulness o de la
conciencia es la que nos permite
discernir reconocer que está pasando
vamos a poner un ejemplo clásico viene
una persona que tú conoces se acerca
mucho a ti pero no te saluda en ese
momento se van a aprender
interpretaciones como no me vio está
molesto conmigo o le habrá pasado algo y
probablemente reaccionemos en base a
esas interpretaciones y lo que eso nos
hizo sentir desde mindfulness o desde la
consciencia sabia nosotros podemos
reconocer lo que ha sucedido en nosotros
y lo que ha sucedido fuera
y como practicamos primero vamos a
hablar más bien de la cualidad compasiva
entonces tras reconocer y discernir lo
que está sucediendo dentro y fuera de
nosotros nos permite conectarnos con el
amor y llevar a la acción el genuino
deseo de liberar a uno y al otro del
sufrimiento entonces por ejemplo tomando
el ejemplo anterior
en lugar de asumir que está molesto
nosotros nos acercamos los saludamos y
le preguntamos si todo bien o más bien
dejamos ir ese evento y hacemos la
vuelta en u para atender aquello que se
ha generado en nuestro interior sin
darle más vueltas al asunto suena
difícil
la conciencia sabia y compasiva está
siempre presente si tú eliges ponerte en
contacto con ellos
intenté por ejemplo no ser consciente de
los sonidos en ese momento
así asequible hasta la conciencia y si
te golpeas una mano la otra no acude a
ella la sostiene y la soba para aliviar
su sufrimiento o si la persona de lado
está apunto a caerse o atorarse no
vacila ayudas así asequible también está
la compasión por uno mismo y por el otro
el problema es que estamos tan pegados a
nuestros pensamientos de nuestro piloto
automático que olvidamos que podemos
vivir de ese modo y por eso es que
existen estas prácticas que nos
recuerdan
de hecho mindfulness un dato curioso una
de sus definiciones ancestrales
significa recordar recordar que
justamente vivir de este modo
pues este instante es único e
irrepetible
y por ello
como practicamos
pues este es un entrenamiento progresivo
que nos enseña paso a paso a atender de
manera compasiva primero empezamos con
la respiración atendiendo la respiración
y las sensaciones corporales así
cultivando la presencia y dejando ir la
tendencia habitual a relacionarnos del
piloto automático luego pasamos a
atender las emociones y los pensamientos
y reconociéndolos como eventos pasajeros
todo ello en la medida de lo posible sin
juzgarlo ni criticarlo mientras más se
hace constante la práctica ésta se va
integrando a la cotidianidad así en
momentos como puede ser al comer al
caminar
inclusive en medio de una reunión del
trabajo te das cuenta que estás
atendiendo desde la sabiduría y la
compasión les vamos a contar el caso de
carolina ella llegó a nosotros con
graves problemas de insomnio tenía mucho
estrés
evidentemente vivía en conflicto consigo
misma con su pareja y con su entorno
en la cuenta que conforme fue
practicando se empezó a dar cuenta que
cada vez que se iba a estos pensamientos
automáticos o cada vez que se iba a las
emociones que a ella le dolían eso para
ella se volvió como un sistema de alarma
decir uy tengo que hacer una pausa en
ese momento ella se atendía respiraba
con calma y de ese lugar de calma se
invitaba a observar la experiencia como
tal nos cuenta que hacía como si
estuviera viendo una película
literalmente que está pasando afuera que
está pasando aquí adentro conmigo
entonces ya no reaccionaba en base a
todas sus interpretaciones y en vez de
eso podía decidir
ella con esta práctica no solamente
aprendió a escucharse y atender sus
necesidades sino aprendió a escuchar y
atender las necesidades del otro y no
solo del otro otro personas si no el
otro como planeta tierra el hecho de que
ella ya no vive en piloto automático
hace que sea más consciente por ejemplo
del uso de plástico incluso hoy nos
cuenta que está ayudando a reforestar la
amazonía
seguro les va a sonar familiar la
siguiente frase
respira 10 veces antes de reaccionar o
actuar
pero nadie nunca no lo dijo cómo hacerlo
y justamente este entrenamiento nos
enseña a hacerlo paso a paso es cómo ir
construyendo el bote por dónde
navegaremos las olas de la vida habrán
días soleados con tumbos calmados y
otros días serán unas enormes olas en
medio de la tormenta pero saben que
sabremos cómo transitar las dignamente
hábilmente y compasiva mente
esto es porque a través de la práctica
de mindfulness se activa la parte más
nueva y evolucionada de nuestro cerebro
la corteza prefrontal que está en esta
zona relacionada a habilidades socio
emocionales como el discernimiento la
empatía y la compasión brindándonos
entonces la posibilidad
puede seguir evolucionando como seres
humanos conscientes en interconexión con
las demás especies y en recíproca
relación con este hogar llamado tierra
así ante cualquier amenaza sea externa o
interna lo que hace esta nueva parte del
cerebro que tenemos por acá es decirle a
la más primitiva tranquilo
esto ya va a pasar
aquí estoy contigo evaluemos y cenamos
no reaccionemos como sentir esta caja
literalmente con estas prácticas lo que
estamos haciendo es dejando ir los
patrones aprendidos y heredados que
fueron útiles para nosotros en algún
momento pero ya no lo son y estamos
creando intencionalmente conscientemente
nuevas conductas que nos apoyen a vivir
de una manera más armoniosa por eso
decimos que las prácticas de mindfulness
y las basadas en compasión es una
reprogramación es una red educación
desde la sabiduría y el amor
y nosotras nos conocimos en el 2010
ambas habíamos pasado dificultades en
adolescencia lo cual nos llevó a
descubrir prácticas que cultivan la
sabiduría y la compasión dentro de la
filosofía budista andina y amazónica
ambas coincidimos que gracias a estas no
terminamos en un lugar de mayor
sufrimiento poco a poco mientras más
cultivamos y desarrollamos prácticas
como y meditación inquietud en
movimiento en relación a las artes y la
naturaleza nos fuimos dando cuenta como
fuimos aprendiendo y seguimos
aprendiendo a apreciar y disfrutar esta
vida plenamente y a poder lidiar con
mayor habilidad y sabiduría los momentos
difíciles
inclusive momentos de estrés nuestros
anteriores trabajos y yo por ejemplo
trabajaba como chef en restaurantes
super exigentes y yo como psicóloga y
maestra en nidos y colegios y ambas
también coincidimos encubrió ha sido muy
provechoso tener esas prácticas desde
muy chiquitas de hecho cuando
compartimos eso con las personas
quienes vienen a nosotras nos dicen la
misma pero porque no hacen en estos los
colegios
es por eso que desde el 2010 nosotros
que fundamos mindfulness perú con la
intención de hacer llegar de difundir
estas prácticas en las nuevas
generaciones que se están enfrentando un
mundo cada vez más complejo y
probablemente más amenazante pero
también con más oportunidades de
rescatar y reconocer esta sabiduría y
práctica ancestral hoy validada por la
ciencia
y eso es lo maravilloso que ya lo
estamos haciendo juntos aquí en perú en
el mundo como sociedad como humanidad
estás inglaterra hace unos años se
proclamó como nación consciente donde ha
integrado como políticas públicas la
práctica de mindfulness en los ámbitos
de salud educación trabajo y sistema
judicial y ojalá pronto más distritos y
regiones de nuestro país hagan lo mismo
también para ello una manera de ser ir
retomando el contacto con esta presencia
en la vida aquí y ahora
es práctica por ello los invitamos a
reposar una mano derecha sobre el pecho
y la mano izquierda sobre el abdomen si
te sientes cómodo cierra los ojos si no
descansa tu mirada delante tuyo
inhalando
exhalando
sintiendo en calma la respiración en el
cuerpo
reconociendo el espacio interno calmo y
receptivo por donde transitan libremente
las sensaciones corporales
inhalando
exhalando
reconociendo que una vez más vivo viva
sentado sostenido sostenida por el suelo
por tus pies
por este auditorio
por las personas que tienes al lado
sostenido por la madre tierra
por el universo entero
cuando te sientas listo vista abre los
ojos
bienvenidos una vez más a hacer lo que
potencialmente ya somos seres
conscientes y llenos de amor capaces de
honrar respetar cuidar y amar la vida
dentro y fuera de nosotros gracias
[Música]